this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you
yes so as she mentioned I'm in the very
smart lab and I'm in a corner Agrotech
in Geneva so my research primarily
focuses on elucidating the master
regulators of sex determination in
trouble oh and how they regulate sex
dimorphism so to give it a little bit of
background shrub willow is a short
rotation bioenergy crop and what that
means is it's grown in high-density
plantings as in this photo here and then
it's cut back every three years and the
wood is chipped and combusted to
generate heat which can either be used
to directly heat buildings or to produce
electricity so my research uses the
species civics for Korea as a model
species this is because it's diploid has
a fully assembled and annotated genome
and is commonly used in shrubbler
breeding programs and willow is somewhat
unique in that it's dioecious so it has
separate male and female plants so you
can see the male catkins here and that
the female catkins here the species
select repair area has a female hetero
comedic system which means that males
are Zizi and females they're ZW and the
sex chromosomes are homomorphic so this
means that they can't really be
distinguished easily using flow
cytometry or karyotyping this is in
contrast as something like human sex
chromosomes which can very easily be
identified and previous research has
localized the sex determination region
to a pair of centromeric region of
chromosome 15 so to kind of give some
broader context about Daichi in in
plants so only about 5% of angiosperms
are dioecious and dioecious plants are
in various different clades and it's
thought to have evolved separately in
each clade so you see a lot of a lot of
variation in the plant kingdom you have
XY system ZW systems some species are
trying shoes so males females and
hermaphrodites as in like papaya and we
also see a lot of variation within
within sally casey which is the willow
family between with in willows as well
as their sister jeana's populous and so
a lot of this work has been done by our
collaborators but some of the most basal
willows that have been analyzed have a
chromosome 17 XY system
and then it's thought that the
sixth-generation region translocated -
chromosome 15 and then at some point
switched to a ZW system and so learning
about the the master regulators at
section six for area will really help us
understand how this this sex
determination has moved between species
and also it presents a unique sex
termination system from others that have
been previously studied in the in the
crop in model plants so this is a elasti
whole chromosome alignment between
chromosome 15w on the y axis and
chromosome 15 z on the x axis and this
kind of highlights some of the features
of chromosome 15 as well as the
challenges of working with homework sex
chromosomes so as you can see from most
of this plot the two chromosomes
Alliance and technically quite well in
this region reading the red arrow is
this which roughly highlights the sex
determination region which has low
recombination so you can see it's
several mega bases long and as a result
contains hundreds of gene annotations
and this lack of recombination is likely
caused in part because it spans the
centromere and also because as an
inversion which this blue arrow points
to since inversions suppress crossovers
from occurring surrounding them another
interesting feature of the chromosome 15
is that what we're turning the W
specific region between these green
arrows here and this is a region where
about 2.9 mega bases of 15w sequence
only lines to about 260 kilobases of 15z
sequence and so much of that region in
there is specific to females only and it
does contain several interesting gene
annotations although it is characterized
by highly repetitive sequences and
tandem ly duplicated genes so to
identify the master regulators of sex
I'm taking both a for genetics and a
reverse genetics approach and so I'll
start with the reverse genetics approach
which involves looking at transcription
factors that are polymorphic between the
15w and 15z haplotypes and so this table
here kind of summarizes those regions of
chromosome 15 that I mentioned earlier
that they're over
length the number of annotated genes and
then the number of transcription factors
and you'll notice that there are about
twenty-eight transcription factors on
chromosome 15 W that are not present on
15z so these are twenty-eight
transcription factors in females that
are either duplicated an extra copy in
females compared to males or not present
in males at all and so we're looking at
those as well but I've also identified
ten synthetic gene annotations between
males and females that are structurally
polymorphic so what this means is they
have both a polymorphic peptide sequence
and 3d structure predictions yield
different models for the 15 xever since
15 w haplotypes so an example is shown
down here this is a homolog in Salix of
tcp 24 in a rabid OPS's which is
involved in shu morphogenesis and ovule
development and so in the canonical
structure of this gene is a as a
helix-turn-helix which is precisely what
we see in 15 W in 15 0 ever it's just
super long helix which indicates a
potential loss of function mutation in
males and so we hope to look at these
polymorphic transcription factors and
the W specific transcription factors
more using gap seek to potentially
identify both where they bind in the
genome and if there are differences in
DNA sequence they bind and I should also
mention that we're so concerned with
structure because the structure of
transcription factors affects how well
they bind and where they bind in the
genome and transcription factors control
a wide set of expression of genes so for
the for genetics approach I plan on
doing a eqtl analysis to potentially
identify cysts and transacting factors
on sex and morphism so we have RNA seek
data from an f2 population of 92 males
and 92 females and this gives us
differential expression data and there
are many genes across the genome they're
differentially expressed this graph here
kind of shows a subset of those and they
segregate quite well between males and
females and so doing this eqtl analysis
we can identify these Sisson transacting
factors and use them to construct gene
networks because even though we see
genes across a genome that
different she expressed based on sex and
morphism we have pathi sized they are
regulated at downstream through
different pathways from the SDR and so
will constructing networks and then
identify nodes in those G network as
potential candidates for further
functional analysis as either being
master regulators of sex or potentially
immediately downstream of master
regulators of sex so another area of
interest in mind are hermaphrodite
willows and so as I mentioned will of
course is dioecious but hermaphrodites
are rarely found we actually have one
clone aligned in our germ plasm and it
happens to be silly for Perea
which works out quite well and we think
it is a ZW genotype which is the female
genotype and this is based on some early
work I've done developing w specific
primers and one aspect of this I'm
interested in is how the flower sex
ratio varies across different
environments and physiological states of
Willow so catkins on hermaphrodites can
range anywhere from all male to all
female flowers and everything in between
and so and you'll also have different
patterns of how many flowers develop so
you'll have some like this where you
have because it's the top half is male
in the bottom half is female some like
this where we see like layers of
different sexes and others like this
where we see completely mixed no matter
between male and female flowers and so
by looking across environment to
potentially identify genes involved in
different physiological responses and
might implicate them in the sex
dimorphism pathway we also have s1 and
s2 Families developed and I've recently
created some outcross families and these
s1 and s2 families are saving from males
females and hermaphrodites and so we can
use these families to get an idea of the
mechanism of the causal mutation for
hermaphroditism and also do genetic
mapping to narrow down in on where that
might be which can also help us identify
genes that might be master regulators of
sex
so for doing flower ratios across
different environments we have our
hermaphrodite line replicated in three
environments at Cornell Agrotech in
Geneva at the Cornell Lake Erie Research
& Extension Laboratory in Portland New
York and at West Virginia University
Morgan and so I've taken cuttings taking
shoots from from all these locations and
done flower accounts on them and also
brought some of them into the greenhouse
early to see what were early flowering
how that affects flower sex and so I've
collected all the data on these and I'm
currently analyzing them but I will say
that we have some very interesting
results and so so yeah come back next
year so I'll follow this up with
controlled environment and plant growth
hormone treatments - first off confirm
if these environmental effects or
physiological effects are actually
influencing flower sex ratio and then
from there we can identify genes that
are involved in these pathways and
implicate them potentially in the sex
dimorphism pathway for future work I
also like to work on polyploid willows
so willows Range employee from 2 X - 12
X and so I'm really curious about what
sex chromosome dosage compensation looks
like in these so for example if you have
a tetraploid as in this it's my vienna
species right here how many w's need to
make a female is one enough do you need
to you know that's a really interesting
question that no one's really looked at
and so we can look at these polyploid
species as well as crosses between these
these species and say like spur Korea of
which we have quite a few and then also
potentially doing colchicine treatment
on Salix propria and subsequent crossing
to generate auto tetraploid x' that have
0 1 or 2 w chromosomes and see how that
affects the sex so just like to conclude
with a few acknowledgments my special
committee particularly my advisor Larry
smart
Jeff Doyle and Josh Rose who are also in
sips and Steve de Fazio who's one of our
collaborators at West Virginia
University and also our collaborators at
Texas Tech and University of
wisconsin-madison who are on the same an
ACEF grant that funds me and have been
doing a lot of work with identifying the
sex termination regions and other
species I also like to thank the folks
at JDI who have been instrumental in the
annotation and the Assembly of the
newest selects prepare genome which is
coming online shortly so you should
check it out and then the members of the
smart lab particularly Craig Carlson and
Eric
who are postdocs who are working on this
project before I started and a few very
helpful as I've been getting started
gingers Oh a visiting scholar in our lab
who's also been working on
hermaphrodites there are wonderful
Cornell or wonderful lab tech team who
has been very very helpful with field
and housework so with that I'd like to
open it up for questions and if they
tried looking at differences in female
ecology to sort of get a handle on that
w specific region he said what
phenotypes right so the that they seen
hermaphrodites in Willow with the Z Z
genotype so developed from male and then
looked at differences in female so the
question was have we seen hermaphrodites
with a Z Z genotype and we don't know so
the the the genome on on world has
really come out recently you know just
in the past few years have a really even
known that sex for Prairie is a ZW
system and I'm working right now to
develop primers to to identify and track
if W chromosomes are present so yeah we
don't know yet hermaphrodite your so
rare as it is we yes certainly once we
do get a genotyping system up and
running and if we do identify more
hermaphrodites yes great question so the
question was what's the difference
between XY system and a ZW system so an
XY system is male hetero comedic system
so that means males are XY females are
xx for example which is the case in
mammals and a lot of plants it has
nothing to do with similarity of the
chromosome just all all XY vs e W does
is identify which sex has that hetero
comedic chromosome sets
ZW the hetero gay me is female and in an
XY it's male there's also a UV system in
[Music]
oh the question was is there a
productive advantage to lose being male
female or hermaphrodite there is some
data that indicates there's some biomass
differences between males and females so
a few minutes have slightly wider crowd
diameters there's some evidence to
indicate that so in a high-density plan
you might want males but for the most
part they're very similar in their their
production we're really interested in
this because with hermaphrodites you can
yeah we don't have any data on
hermaphrodites there's only a few that
we've ever observed but you know we're
really interested in this because it
affects breeding efforts of willow if
you can have a hermaphrodite that
changes your entire breeding scheme any
further questions okay
[Music]
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu